welcome back I gotta come up with a new
intro hey it's great to be back
all right I think that works no one can
over share like the prince with red hair
he embarrassed his family for fun now
his tell-alls number one it's true
Prince Harry's book has now become the
fastest selling non-fiction book in the
history of the UK selling 400 000 copies
on Tuesday it's the only book to ever
sell more copies on its first day than
Harry Potter which also was a work of
fiction
foreign
anyway
the book also reveals a whole bunch of
weird crap a text message fight between
Megan and Kate how does a husband get
that and why does he care
also how Prince Charles used to do
headstands in his underwear every day to
alleviate injuries from Polo not polio
Polo
Polo
stupid
there and then there was that time that
Harry suffered frostbite on his penis
from a trip to the North Pole
hmm you sure he didn't get that from
Megan
it's contagious frostbite
I think I don't know I'm not a doctor
the best part Harry's book is titled
spare which comes from Harry's claim
that he was bred only to offer spare
organs to Prince William
I know although they're both out of luck
generating hair plugs
Anthony was born to provide spare parts
you know call me a fuddy duddy but I
preferred bait way back when they
created heirs the old-fashioned way you
know by banging their cousins
cat you are a huge fan of royalty you've
been following a fear what what is
Harry's last name
I have no idea is that funny I know
everything about this guy now I know
they did a frost pitting penis but I
don't know his last name is it of yeah
that's because men love talking about
their yes
even bad stories anytime they can fit
that in there what about or anywhere yes
that is thank you yeah
anyway we were all thinking it and you
said it yeah like I said by the way
aren't you pissed off I mean isn't it
what husband the pre-printed actual
texts between the two sisters in the
book what kind of person does that okay
I just no everybody's got to be really
careful and not hang out with them ever
yeah because I trust them no but yeah
because especially because this was a
tell-all right which means they told it
all and now they're gonna need to tell
more so they're they're gonna need to
find other people to get dirt from and
then that'll be in the next book so if
they invite you over it's because they
want to you know share your love the one
time this person came over and did this
and that'll be their next book so they
better not have a single friend ever
again if you know what's good for you
yeah so you can't trust this girl you
can't trust him bill
um do you really think he believes that
he was bred for spare parts I mean it's
called SP I mean so you say that he he
was going to provide what organs for
organs yeah not the fridge have you seen
some of these party pics of Harry back
in the day I mean did anybody check with
William as to whether or not he was
interested
but I'm going to do a double take but
I'll tell you they wanted privacy right
yeah nothing says privacy like a 400
page Memoir exactly nothing says privacy
like let me tell you they are all about
making the money they're making the
money it was never about privacy it's
about the presidents see what I did a
little uh yeah huh listen I watched I
watched the six-part documentary on
Netflix shame on you so you don't have
to shame on you what did you learn at
1.5 speed
um entirely self-indulgent yeah yeah but
Netflix has a new feature you're gonna
love it you can watch movies faster than
you ever could before you can speed
right through that sucker let me tell
you this is one you want to say I think
they call it the compagno yeah but
um
I sometimes like I this when you work
with a lot of white people sometimes
you forget they don't have the the sense
that we have like I know if a building's
about to go down I leave I don't go to
check to see what happened yeah well you
guys are like hey let's investigate
y'all go right ahead and yeah I leave
how can you not
tell that he did not write this book
She Wrote This Book
what what man
has saved text messages from his girl
that's so true No all he did see that
face that was his face during the entire
time while she told every dirty secret
she could
remember your dad used to do handstands
in his underwear and he was like well
that was because he got hurt from Polo
that's in the book it's in the book
remember that time the reason why you
told me that you weren't that big is
because you had frostbite that I told
you that in confidence
it's in the book your brother just was
using it for spare parts
and no one had the ability in the room
to say that that doesn't work quite like
that
at all like if he gets shot they're not
gonna run you over to the side like they
wouldn't let you outside you'd been in a
glass of fluid your entire life yeah in
case of injury break glass use Arm like
this she wrote it
she's gonna keep all the money in about
two and a half years very broken broke
guy is gonna be calling daggling hey is
it okay if I could click like he's done
like do not read this book this is her
book with his face on it yeah that I
didn't even consider it but that makes
sense the text everything Rob have you
been following this as closely as I have
you said before the segment I know
nothing about royalty no I've I've been
studying this issue for three or four
minutes now yes
and I've come to this conclusion about
Prince Harry that an amazing change
history yes
this this erotic pleasure I actually no
longer deny myself
never
never
again
is Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else